die katholischen bischöfe treffen sich
gerade in fulda zu ihrer
herbstvollversammlung vier tage lang
soll es darum gehen ob und wie sich die
katholische kirche verändern sollte
die katholische führung ist auf dem weg
reformen soll es geben die frage ist nur
welche
und damit es nicht allzu weit geht am
ende kam gerade noch rechtzeitig post
vom papst aus rom über zentrale fragen
entscheiden nicht die deutschen bischöfe
sondern die weltkirche schreibt
franziskus eine dieser zentralen fragen
ist die welche rolle frauen in der
katholischen kirche übernehmen sollen
und darüber möchte ich heute abend gerne
sprechen mit michael maas er ist
katholischer priester und kümmert sich
sozusagen um die nachwuchsarbeit in der
katholischen kirche schönen guten abend
nach freiburg hamas schönen guten abend
trotzdem nicht ganz christina online
sternberg heute zur stellvertretung weil
frau zimmermann krank ist aber wir
richten schöne grüße aus und ich hoffe
wir führen trotzdem ein gutes und
angeregtes gespräch
was finden sie dass frauen mehr mehr
verantwortung in der kirche übernehmen
sollten
ich finde es ganz wichtig dass das
deutlich wird dass die kirche aus frauen
und männer gleichermaßen gebildet wird
und dazu ist es notwendig dass frauen in
der kirche auch auftauchen dass sie eine
stimme bekommen dass sie auch
verantwortungsvolle tätigkeiten ausüben
das ist ganz selbstverständlich so
auftauchen es nicht dasselbe wie
gleichberechtigt frauen und männer
bilden gemeinsam kirche und nur so kann
kirche auch gemeinsam gestaltet sein und
sie spielen jetzt auf die verschiedenen
ämter in der kirche ab und da ist es
natürlich so dass eben das haben sie ja
auch eben ist ja vielfach auch schon
diskutiert und das ist ja auch so dass
eben momentan das amt des priesters oder
eines bischofs auch den männern
vorbehalten ist das heißt aber nicht
dass deswegen die frauen weniger wert
sein sondern das heißt einfach dass es
verschiedene
und ämter gibt und die unterschiedlich
wahrgenommen werden
aber um den punkt noch mal ein ganz klar
zu machen damit unsere user und
zuschauer genau ungefähr verordnen
können wie ihre position ist frauen im
priesteramt würden sie sagen nein das
ist ja nicht nur etwas also wo es dann
darum geht was will ich jetzt gerade
haben sondern als kirche sind wir auch
an das gebunden was jesus christus uns
von anfang an mit gegeben hat und und da
ist es eben so dass er zu beginn die
zwölf apostel eingesetzt hat und alles
männer eingesetzt hat und das ich daraus
dann auch laufe der zeit dass priester
amt das bischofsamt entwickelt hat und
dass es die jahrhunderte hindurch eben
dann immer männer waren die diese ämter
ausgeübt haben
und da können wir jetzt einfach drüber
weg gehen so wichtig und so wertvoll uns
auch der gedanke der gleichberechtigung
ist und so wertvoll und wichtig es auch
ist dass frauen und männer gemeinsam
kirche bilden und auch in
verantwortungsvoller position dafür
eintreten da bin ich ja schon auch schon
an vielen stellen
damit sind wir schon quasi in der
theologisch inhaltliche begründung und
das würde ich sehr gerne vertiefen bevor
wir das machen würde ich nur gerne
gemeinsam und auf den stand der dinge in
dieser diskussion bringen frauen als
priesterinnen nicht möglich heißt es
nach wie vor aus der katholischen kirche
die begründung jesus hat nur männer als
apostel ausgesucht und genau diesen hat
christus auch ein mann sein amt
übertragen
dieser tradition ist die kirche
verpflichtet gott gewollt so lautet es
in einem schreiben von papst johannes
paul linz weiter dass die kirche
keinerlei vollmacht hat frauen die
priesterweihe zu spenden und dass sich
alle gläubigen der kirche endgültig an
diese entscheidung zu halten haben
daran will auch der aktuelle papst
franziskus nichts ändern
endgültig abfinden mit der rolle der
frau wollen sich viele gläubige aber
keinesfalls
seit jahrzehnten kämpfen der katholische
deutsche frauenbund und die katholische
frauengemeinschaft für eine
geschlechtergerechte kirche und die
initiative maria 2.0 rief zum streik auf
für einen zugang von frauen zu allen
ämtern auch als priesterinnen ein erster
schritt wäre die diakonenweihe diese
dürfen taufen trauen beerdigen und
predigen aber nicht die messfeier leiten
oder die beichte abnehmen papst
franziskus hatte 2016 dazu eine
kommission aufgestellt die die frage der
diakoninnen historisch untersuchen
sollen endergebnis noch offen
dass sich insgesamt an der position der
frau was tun muss ist wohl angekommen
die katholische kirche in deutschland
hat sich jedenfalls eine frauenquote
verordnet bis 2023 sollen 30 prozent der
leitungsfunktionen mit frauen besetzt
sein
tja wie wir gerade gesehen haben gibt es
eine pragmatische ebene mit den
leitungsfunktionen und der quote darauf
würde ich gerne ein bisschen später
kommen und erst noch mal beim
theologischen bleiben und das noch ein
bisschen vertiefen was sie mit den
aposteln gesagt haben es gibt ja dazu
auch unterschiedliche meinungen auch was
bibel exegeten innerhalb der
universitäten und der kirche angeht es
gibt durchaus die position dass jesus
auch weibliche anhänger hatte glaube ich
unstrittig dass jesus weibliche anhänger
hatte und das ist gerade viele frauen
auch gefolgt sind und dass er auch ganz
bewusst auf frauen in seiner nachfolge
gefördert hat nur eben als die zwölf
apostel hat er nur männer eingesetzt
also und das ist keineswegs so dass
jesus gesagt hätte ich möchte die frauen
draußen haben im gegenteil von anfang an
gehören die frauen zur kirche mit dazu
als wir
natürlicher bestandteil was ist denn mit
dem argument dass das gerade auch was
die apostel frage und die frage der
definition nach amt in der kirche eine
übersetzungs problematik ist eine
übersetzungs problematik wie das
verstehe ich also dass man das dienende
und das nachfolgende zum beispiel aus
dem griechischen in der entwicklung der
bibelübersetzungen dass man daraus aus
den ursprünglich frauen und männer
gleich berechtigten dienenden
tätigkeiten in der gefolgschaft jesu im
laufe der jahrzehnte und jahrhunderte
eine quasi patriarchalische
deutungshoheit übergestülpt hat also das
ist mir nicht bekannt dass er so ist
also wie gesagt von anfang an waren
frauen und männern gemeinsam in der
nachfolge jesu aber jesus hat ganz
bewusst die männer als sie zwölf apostel
eingesetzt und von dort heraus haben
sich dann die ämter in der kirche auch
entwickelt dann auch das presbyter abend
dann das was das priesteramt heute ist
oder das bischofsamt und das haben dann
eben männer ausgeübt indem
gemeindeordnungen die wir da auch
nachlesen können aus frühchristlicher
zeit
ich würde gern in diesem bezug noch ein
argument aufgreifen nämlich dass das
jesus selbst ja auch ein mann gewesen
ist auch das wird als argument gerne
angeführt und dazu würde ich gerne
gabriele von karas hören sie ist
vertreterin von maria 2.0
es wird argumentiert jesus war ein mann
und deswegen kann nur ein mann jesus am
altar vertreten oder einen gottesdienst
leiten
aber jesus war nicht mein mann er war
auch ein jude
er war ein wanderprediger er war ein
zimmermann und dann könnten jetzt alle
zimmermänner auch kommen sagen also wir
haben den gleichen beruf wie jesus wir
sind dafür prädestiniert die botschaft
jesu glaubhaft zu verkünden
absurd genau und genau so absurd ist es
jesus nur auf sein geschlecht zu
reduzieren
man muss vielleicht noch dazu sagen
maria 2.0 ist die frauenbewegung in der
katholischen kirche die gerade sehr
lautstark ihre meinung kund tut und für
mehr gleichberechtigung in der kirche
kämpft und auch in fulda zum beispiel
sehr aktiv aufgetreten ist herr maß
halten sie ist auch noch also anderem
ist es anders fragen ich nehme an sie
halten es nicht für absurd jesus nur auf
sein geschlecht zu reduzieren sowie
strocka von cara es gerade getan hat
genannt hat jesus allein uns sein
geschlecht zu reduzieren würde der sache
auch nicht gerecht werden
aber ihn von seinem geschlecht völlig zu
trennen wäre auch nicht richtig es gilt
eben es gibt eben dieses alte bild auch
der kirche dass jesus christus der
bräutigam ist und die kirche die braut
und und das hat sich als ein sehr
wichtiges bild auch für für die kirche
heraus entwickelt aber mir persönlich
ist es viel wichtiger
eben das dass jesus die apostel als
männer eingesetzt hat und dass sich
daraus entwickelt hat warum sind denn
aus ihrer sicht wenn man sagt okay das
ist schon immer so gewesen okay aber
warum sind inhaltlich aus ihrer sicht
frauen die schlechteren priester das
sage ich gar nicht frauen sind sehr gute
seelsorgerinnen und und das ist sicher
so dass sie auf diese art und weise sehr
viel auch beitragen können zum aufbau
der kirche also das würde ich nicht
sagen dass er frauen schlechtere
seelsorgerinnen sind wenn man sich
darauf einigt dass gott ein freund des
lebens ist und das leben nur bestehen
kann aus der partnerschaft zwischen mann
und frau und wir im jahr 2019 über
gleichberechtigung zwischen paten meinem
mann und frau sprechen warum sollte ein
gott dann nicht wollen dass das was sie
gerade alles gesagt haben an positiven
was frauen in die kirche einbringen in
seelsorgerischen ämtern zum beispiel
nicht auch als priesterinnen tun können
ja ich glaube das ist das ein
entscheidender punkt der da meine sachen
sind richtig gesehen wird ist eben die
frage was heißt gleichberechtigung heißt
es dass alle genau das gleiche tun oder
heißt es dass das was auch an
verschiedenen getan wird den gleichen
wert hat und ich glaube da müssen wir
viel stärker darauf achten und das dass
wir da nicht werten von
unterschiedlichen dingen und sie haben
jetzt das bild von von mann und frau
gebracht von der familie gebracht und
ich glaube dass das kennen wir auch von
der familie dass es so ist dass der
vater und mutter einfach auch
unterschiedliche rollen haben und auch
von den kindern unterschiedlich
wahrgenommen werden und trotzdem würde
würden die kinder nicht sagen mama oder
papa sind für uns viel wichtiger wie
jeweils der andere sondern dass es da
einfach auch verschiedenes gibt und dass
aber gerade auch dann wenn ich das
verschiedene gemeinsam als bereicherung
betrachte dass es dann erst das gesamte
bild ergibt
ich würde gerne einen kommentar einer
userin auf facebook mit einbeziehen
verena katrien schreibt da es wird keine
katholiken mehr geben wenn sich nichts
ändert sollte das nicht priorität haben
ja also da wäre ich mir nicht so sicher
wie diese user rinde sitzt dort gerade
schreibt
es wird ja immer auch gesagt die frauen
fordern dass jetzt die frauen wollen
dass ich kenne aber auch sehr viele
frauen auch sehr viele junge frauen die
genau sagen nein das wollen wir nicht
und wir wollen uns an dem orientieren
was jesus christus uns mitgegeben hat
und was die tradition der kirche die
jahrhunderte über auch immer weiter
getragen hat ich würde gern der frage
der userin noch mal eine zahl
nachschieben und damit sind wir quasi
schon von der theologischen auf der
pragmatischen ebene nämlich wenn man
sich die zahlen anguckt laut
bischofskonferenz haben 2018 mehr als
200.000 gläubige die kirche verlassen
das war das jahr mit den zweitmeisten
kirchenaustritten seit ende des zweiten
weltkriegs sicher dass sie keine frauen
zu priesterinnen weihen wollen
ich bin sehr traurig über jeden der die
kirche verlässt weil ich die kirche also
ein ort erleben wo ich sehr viel
hoffnung geschenkt bekomme wo ich im
gebet trost finden und halt findet
und mir tut es für jeden der das nicht
so entdecken kann für sich und trotzdem
glaube ich nicht dass diese fragen die
ich war jetzt die frage nach der weihe
der frau dafür entscheiden und
ausschlaggebend sind was sonst wird es
ja aus der evangelischen kirche
niemanden geben der austritt aber das
sind die austrittszahlen sogar leider
noch höher wenn man sich die gründe
anguckt dann zeigt eine studie die der
bischofskonferenz sekretär langläufer
zitiert hat dass viele menschen diese
diesen austritt begründen dass zum
beispiel initiativen wie maria 20 zeigen
dass menschen sich veränderungen in der
kirche wünschen
ja also wie gesagt dass sie mal ein
bisschen in der schwierigkeit also
manche wünschen sich diese veränderungen
nicht die die spannende frage die wir
uns als kirche immer zu stellen haben
lautet wie können wir das evangelium des
jesus christus uns mitgegeben hat und
was er uns da als auftrag mit gegeben
hat wie können wir das so in die zeit
heute mädchen übernehmen das dass das
was er uns da an wertvollem mitgegeben
hat auch erkannt werden kann
das ist sozusagen die entscheidende
frage frau dem wir als kirche immer
stehen genau der punkt mit in die zeit
hin übernehmen den spricht gabriele von
kara ist auch an und auch das können wir
uns nochmal anhören wenn sie die erste
seite der bibel auf landes steht drin
gott schuf den menschen dass mann und
frau schuf sie punkt und dazu gibt es
eigentlich nichts zu sagen die frauen
sind gleichberechtigt wir leben in einer
demokratie wo frauen gleich würdig und
auch gleiche rechte haben und es erwarte
ich auch in der katholischen kirche
das ist also die gegenposition das heißt
sie sehen viele frauen sind einfach
nicht damit zufrieden mit der
wertschätzung die sie ganz bestimmt
erfahren die sie ja auch genannt haben
die die empfunden wird in der
katholischen kirche für die arbeit der
frauen in denen ihnen zur verfügung
stehenden ämtern aber es ist den frauen
einfach nicht genug für mich ist die
frage gibt es eigentlich in mehr wenn
ich jetzt die priesterweihe habe oder
gibt es dieses oder was macht es dann
aus und und da muss ich doch sagen das
entscheidende was sozusagen für uns als
als gläubige menschen in der kirche das
wichtigste ist die taufe aus der heraus
ich dann mein leben gestaltet und da
kommt eigentlich in der priesterweihe
gar nichts dazu was ich jetzt sagen
würde das ist ein mehr sondern das ist
lediglich eine andere aufgabe die mir da
auch zuwächst und trotzdem gibt es
manchmal bei den leuten so das bild ja
als als priester da hat man da irgendwie
mehr und das bett war wenn sie dann
sagen
beten sie für mich sie haben ja ein
besseren draht zum himmel
und da veiga ich mich immer oder ich
sage immer ich bin gerne für sie ja aber
ich weigere mich das zu akzeptieren dass
ich als pfarrer an besseren draht zum
himmel hat als als ein anderer getaufter
oder eine getaufte jeder christ jede
kristin hat den mittelbaren zugang zu
jesus christus zum dreifaltigen gott und
darauf kommt es doch eigentlich wenn sie
es das ansprechen und sagen was gibt es
denn mehr dann drehe ich mal die frage
herum und frage was gibt es denn weniger
was verlieren die männer in der
katholischen kirche wenn frauen
priesterinnen sind darum geht es gar
nicht also ich habe ja versucht es
darzulegen dass wir sozusagen von jesus
christus her dass als stiftung haben und
und wir müssen da schauen ja was ist so
wichtig dass es durch die zeit getragen
werden soll und was kann sich auch
ändern und etwa
man darf auch nicht also zum beispiel
können wir jetzt sagen ja
bei den bei den juristischen gaben beim
letzten abendmahl hat jesus mein und
brot genommen die ungesäuerten brote und
jetzt könnte man das aber irgendwie
ändern wenn man in eine andere kultur
geht dass man dann sagt ja da gibt es
gar kein brot sondern die essen
eigentlich reis dann nehmen wir reis
aber auch in anderen kulturen hat mal
gesagt nee das ist so wichtig dass da
können wir nicht einfach drüber weg
gehen und und dann ist die frage ja wie
sieht es aus an dieser anderen stelle
ich das so ist das so wichtig und da
haben die paves stadt etwa papst
johannes paul der zweite sehr auch mit
sich gerungen und und hat dann gesagt
nee wir können da nicht einfach darüber
wir gehen wir können uns da nicht drüber
weg setzen
aber was wir können nicht zu zeigen dass
wir gemeinsam mit den frauen die kirche
gestalten dass es da ganz viele
möglichkeiten gibt sich einzubringen
ich beobachte hier so ein bisschen was
auf facebook und youtube und twitter
passiert und da schreibt zum beispiel
eine userin freier köhler die erste
apostel in war maria magdalena by the
way aber keine angst ich möchte jetzt
nicht wieder den diskurs vom anfang
aufgreifen aber ich würde gerne quasi
eine eine abschließende frage an sie
stellen zu dem thema warum sollte sich
eine frau im jahr 2009 10 in der
katholischen kirche als gläubige in
welcher funktion auch immer willkommen
fühlen
frauen und männer freuen sich in der
kirche willkommen fühlen weil die kirche
ein ort ist an dem sie jesus christus
begegnen können von dem hoffnung aus
geht von dem heil ausgeht der in den
sakramenten für mein eigenes leben
stärkung bringt wo ich im gebet getragen
bin wo ich ein großes miteinander
erleben auch im glauben in der
glaubensgemeinschaft und und ich glaube
da gibt es ganz ganz viele gründe
weshalb man sich da willkommen fühlen
darf sagt michael maas vielen herzlichen
dank für dieses gespräch
nach freiburg ihnen noch einen
schönen abend und ihnen vielen vielen
dank fürs zuschauen
[Musik]